hello everyone I would have uploaded
this video some two hours ago but my
internet service provider failed to
provide me with the service of Internet
that's very unfortunate but you know it
is as it is and it's not all that easy
to come by internet these days so now
that i've managed to figure figure
things out we're gonna enjoy a very nice
game from round three of the 2018 bill
chess festival it's Magnus Carlsen with
the white pieces against Peter Svidler
and I don't know if you've seen my
previous video that very nice game a
silver played against a girl goddess
there I mentioned that I'm really
looking forward to this game and let me
tell you the game did not disappoint
it's a very nice night of variation I'm
sure neither firm would have been proud
how both of them played this you know
with the black and white pieces both and
I've mentioned in my previous video that
sorry about that here we have before
this game's fiddler had a positive score
against Magnus Carlsen so regarding
classical time format he defeated Magnus
Carlsen 2 times cos and beat him once
and they played 12 draws so I mentioned
this was a very nice opportunity for
Carlsen to even out the score now well
ok without further ado let's check out
this amazing game across and opens the
game with E 4 as he does have the white
pieces and we even have a photo of this
very nice moment there you have it
could be one of the one of the better
photos I've ever seen of the first move
being played
it's from the official bill a chess
festival website I'm not sure who took
it I'm pretty sure it's Leonard Oates
but I will have to check it as there is
something wrong with their Dropbox
folder at the moment but I will put a
link in the description below so you can
enjoy it you know they'll probably fix
it
so ke4 and as I already mentioned the
night of hat will be on the board so
let's just go right to it c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight f3 d6 d4 C
captures Knight captures in the knight
to f6 Knight to c3 and silver goes for
the knight of variation a6 and here
after not not too much thinking Carson
goes Bishop to g5 after the game in an
interview filled room
that bit of the g5 is one of the moves
why he stopped playing the night off as
there are simply too many lines you have
to you know be be aware of but he goes
for the sharpest line Knight B to d7 we
have king a queen to e2 by Carson and
now h6 either forcing girls and to move
the bishop back maybe three three maybe
to h4 or to capture on f6 Crossing goes
Bishop to h4 and now comes g6 we have f4
and here s wheeler did consider what to
play for quite some time he v is the
main line here and he mentioned this
after the game but as Carson really
played quickly up until this point he
didn't want to challenge him to the main
line so okay he decided for Queen to c7
Carson Castle queenside and we have
Bishop to g7 g for now really expanding
now a lot of ideas are possible v g5 f5
you have to consider everything and here
silver played the sharpest move e5 and
he said that he did have to calculate a
lot of things because you can't play e5
without considering Knights to be five
nights C to be five you have to really
see what what's going on here
of course you can't move the Queen
immediately to somewhere like a five
then the the d6 point will become weak
so the the strongest move is to capture
tonight and then you have to see that
after Knight capture some b-52 Queen is
under attack and now you have to play
something so this is what's wheeler said
he said that he thought he thought that
it wasn't really that great because of
Quinta c6 now with a double attack
against the e4 pawn but then calls and
shown a very nice variation rook
captures and d6 attacking the Queen
Queen captures on e4 and now the the
spectacular rook to e6 check and now you
see the problem if you capture the rook
pawn captures you get Knight to d6 check
you lose the Queen and the game if you
don't capture it if you move the King
for example to d8
then this is a even worse Queen captures
Queen the knight is pinned you cannot
capture here and of course if King to f8
then comes the the Punisher rook to e8
check once again if you capture with the
King you get a rock to d6 check
this comes with it with a nice fork on
the Queen and if you don't capture it
well you have to capture it if you
capture with the knight then of course
the knight is no longer protecting the
Queen so the Queen is free for grabs
so Queen captures on e4 again you lose
the Queen and the game so he had to
figure out a lot of things when he
played e5 but fortunately cousin decided
not to do this as you know it's too too
complicated to calculate and it's good
that he didn't because after captures
captures probably swiller would have
found that Queen to c6 losses and then
after he would have played Queen to a5
and all would be well
Knight captures King moves to a fake and
now black you can continue playing this
position but okay after E 5 crossing
plate F captures on e5 we have Knight
captures on e5 and now a ch3 solidifying
the position you know you have to
protect the g4 pawn Bishop to e6 Queen
to f2 and now Knight F to d7 and this is
another beautiful moment in this game
cross and can play a lot of things
Knight captures on e6 rook to g'wan King
to be one for you know some reason if
you enjoy playing moves like King to be
one a3 is an idea but cousin plays a
move that is very characteristic for the
night of Bishop to b5 offering a full
piece here so what do you do here one of
my favorite games in the night or for a
bishop to be if I was played is the
original brunch time versus night or
okay pawn to b5 was pushed there and
then Bishop captures was played but it's
definitely a classic if you haven't seen
it I will put a link to it in the
description below I've made a video on
it it's quite a nice game I definitely
recommend it so here swiller
disregards the bishop and he simply
castles capturing the bishop would not
go very nicely for black as after knife
captures your queen is under attack you
have to move it Queen c5 and now comes
the knife captures an d6 and black is
lost whatever he plays you can capture
this Knight you can capture this night
with that whichever Knight you capture
it doesn't really matter if you capture
this night you get 97 check with this
monster fork you lose the Queen and the
game of course
and after this Queen to c5 move Knight
captures on e6 you could also choose to
capture this Knight but it's no better
Knight capture some a 6 and now we see
that the bishop
which for is slicing all the way here
the queen is slicing all the way here
King has nowhere to go you have to
capture the night and then rock after
screen of course wins the game
so after this Bishop to b5 move Fielder
quickly castles so we have castles Bush
or capture son d7 Queen capture son d7
and now while you could play a lot of
things here for example Bishop to a5
force a trade of the dark square Bishop
that Bishop on g7 filter has it's a very
nice piece Carson is already 2 out of 2
in this tournament this is round 3 and
he really you know developed a taste for
a full point so he wants to go for more
so not know reverse here Knight to f5 so
what do you do here the bishop is under
attack
you can never allow this Knight to
capture the dark square Bishop as then
white will be too strong with his dark
square bishop and also there is a double
attack against the d6 pawn with the
knight and the rock here so the
strongest move is the captured swinger
capture captures the knight and now we
have G chapters on f5 and now the bishop
is under attack the only square for the
bishop is c4 but fiddler doesn't move
the bishop he plays King to h7 why
doesn't he move the bishop I mean if you
can save the piece why not because if
bishop here then f6 is coming if you
want to keep on saving pieces the bishop
to h8 then comes Queen to f4 with an
attack against the h6 pawn Knight to g6
attacking the Queen Queen captures on h6
and now this position would be
unplayable for white there are simply
too many resources here rook to G 1 is
coming he 5 is coming the d6 pawn is
pinned from the rook here Knight to e4
perhaps the g5 is coming Queen to h7
would be a terrible threat I don't think
this would be playable for black at all
so after G captures on at 5 as fiddler
doesn't save the piece rather King to h7
and now across and could capture the
bishop but if you capture the bishop
then pawn captures opens up an attack
towards your queen after Queen moves row
k c8 you can simply continue playing
this game black is perfectly fine here
even better
so after this King to h7 Carlsen
continues his onslaught rook H 2 G 1 and
once again if you try to get away for
example Bishop to c4 then you get
rook captures on g7 with check King
captures Queen to g3 check King moves
and now of course although you can see
it Queen captures on e5 a very nice idea
you have to capture and then rope
capture 77 cousin would be up upon
probably winning this game
so after Luke H to g1 swindler doesn't
allow rook captures and g7 Bishop to h8
displayed and here again a very critical
moment in the game
cross in place Bishop to g3 also
possible was Bishop to g5 Carson decides
not to go for this as it's it's winning
in so many ways but it's not winning if
Bishop to g5 the strongest is the
capture it pawn captures and after rook
captures okay now white is threatening
checkmate here with Queen to h4 and it's
you know depending on what you play and
how you decide to defend this you know
you will either win or not win this game
if Bishop to g7 preparing to meet this
move with Bishop to h6 then comes rook
to h5 check King moves and now f6
attacking the bishop here as you can't
really save everything you have to give
up something Knight to g6 blocking the G
file now comes a rook to g1 and after
Bishop to a trade not allowing and he
captures Queen to f4 is coming of course
then I painted the Queen is threatening
to come here to h6 you cannot allow this
and there's really nothing for you to
play here after Bishop captures Queen
captures there would be no defense
against a rock to h8 checkmate as the
night and g6 is pinned but fortunately
for black after Luke to g5 you don't
have to defend would bash up to g7 you
can defend with Knight to g6 not the
easiest move to find what you know you
have to give up your extra material
immediately after F captures F captures
here opening up an attack towards the
Queen Queen to h4 check King moves to g7
now comes rugby to g1 attacking here and
now you can either well the best thing
for you would do is to run away with the
King King to f7 and now if you try rock
to f1 check King simply goes back
forcing White's to repeat moves and if
you capture then you get Bishop captures
on c3 pawn captures and now King to e8
the black king escape
and black will enjoy his extra piece
still it's a very short position but not
not likely wife can push for anything
here
so Carson decides not to go for this
sharpest of lines rather he plays Bishop
to g3 there are some threats here of
course f6 blocking the bishop and then
Bishop captures Knight would be it would
be very nice
also he's preparing Bishop to Bishop to
f4 so the Queen can come to h4 we have
roped the c8 finally sweedler brings his
last inactive piece in the game and now
we have Bishop to f4
cousin would very much enjoy playing
Queen to h4 followed by Queen captures
on h6 checkmate so Svidler doesn't allow
it
Queen to e7 blocking across and from
coming to h4 f captures an e6 now
finally cousin grabs the extra piece F
captures on e6 and Queen to g3 unpinning
we have rocked g8 attacking Carlson's
Queen Queen to f2 and now rook to G look
G to f8 again preparing to to pile up on
the pinned bishop cousin again again on
pins Queen to g3 and now Rock to g8
Queen F to direct the position has
repeated itself three times and it's a
draw by repetition of moves it's already
here after room GT f8 there was nothing
to do here you could block this somehow
like this but then then it's actually
black would be on the counter-attack
after night comes to c4 already a double
attack against the b2 Pony v is a threat
attacking the pin piece and after c3
blocking this c5 is coming of course now
Queen to g3 does say white because Queen
to g6 is a threat of checkmate but after
black stops this and white retrieves the
bishop it's actually black who will be
on the attack here so yeah definitely
you know a possibility but today decided
you know both of them played a very nice
game both of them are satisfied with the
result in the tournament so far so you
know no reason to spoil it after Queen
to f2 they agreed to a draw and this
beautiful beautiful game was created
with so many tactics and so many hidden
resources I'm sure neither
would applaud both of them how they
played it you know played his variation
with the white and black pieces both so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it once again we can we can
check out this very nice photo of
Carlson's first move I'm really enjoying
it definitely one of the better photos
of efore of pre e4 ever ever made so
hope you're enjoying the this as well I
hope you're enjoying the coverage of the
tournament so far in order to check out
the links in the description below you
know some of the other photos from the
bill chess festival you know you can
enjoy them do check out the game branch
ten versus night off if you haven't seen
it it's really really an amazing game
and that's it for now thank you all for
watching as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and I'll see you
soon perhaps with some of the other
games from round 3 but then again we do
have to continue our Bobby Fischer
series thank you all and I'll see you
soon